اشباح روسيا النووية تتحرك في
البحر للمرة الاولى منذ ثلاثين
عاما. فما هو الهدف? وطائرة
بوتين الحربية تخترق اجواء
الناتو ليجتمع وزراء الحلف
وهولندا ترد. واشنطن تدعو
مواطنيها لمغادرة الاراضي
الروسية حالا. واوكرانيا تبيع ما
تملك لتحصل على اسلحة الغرب
ورائحة الابتزاز تنتشر. فماذا عن
عادات المزعومة. الاجسام الطائرة
ترعب الامريكيين والناتو انها
انشطة روسية صينية مكثفة للتجسس
علينا. وبايدن يشكل جيشا من
المحققين للتحقق من الامر
والليزر الصيني يخترق السفن
الفلبينية وامريكا تتحرك لتنجد
حليفتها. طفلة كيم جونج تعاقب
الشعب الكوري وزلزال تركيا يذيب
الخلافات مع اليونان والخسائر
يوما بعد اخر. وقصص مأساوية قد
تصبح مستقبلا افلاما في هوليود.
وبعد سقوط نيزك في السعودية
فرنسا تعلن عن سقوط نيزك اخر في
اراضيها. انهيال الضربات
الروسية. ضربات روسية غزيرة في
اوكرانيا وخارجها نطاقها يتوسع.
روسيا تستميت للوصول لهدفها
والقلق الغربي يبلغ درجة القصوى
ليخرج الامين العام لحلف الناتو
محذرا من ان الرئيس الروسي بوتين
يستعد لشن حرب اكبر في اوكرانيا
مضيفا ان نوعية الاسلحة قد تتغير
بحسب مسار المعارك بوتين وسع
نطاق هجماته فعلا. وهنا وزارة
الدفاع الهولندي تطلق مقاتلتين
هولنديتين من طراز اف خمسة
وثلاثين لتعترض تشكيلا من ثلاث
طائرات حربية روسية بالقرب من
بولندا واقتادتها الى خارج تلك
المنطقة. اليكم المصدر.
فها هي النرويج تتحدث عن خطوة
نووية روسية في عرض البحر هي
الاولى منذ ثلاثين عاما. اذ ذكرت
وكالة المخابرات النرويجية ان اي
اس ان سفن اسطول الشمالي الروسي
توجهت نحو البحر. وعلى متنها
اسلحة نووية تكتيكية. وهنا كل
يعد العدة وكل يتحضر للحرب.
فوزراء الدفاع الناتو يجتمعون.
ووزير الدفاع الامريكي يعلن ان
موسكو تراهن على انقسام حلف
الناتو. لكن الحلف متحد اكثر من
اي وقت مضى في مواجهة روسيا حسب
قوله. ومن هناك اضافن ان الحلف
تواصل تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمة
الدفاع الجوي والدبابات مؤكدا
على وجوب تكثيف الدعم العسكري
وتلبية احتياجات اوكرانيا
الملحة. حتى ان الناتو يناقش
مسألة امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات اف
ستة عشر وفق صحيفة فاينانشال
تايمز اليكم المصدر. يضغط
مسئولون عسكريون في البنتاجون
لانتزاع الموافقة على ارسال
الطائرات لمساعدتها في المعارك
ضد الصواريخ والمسيارات الروسية.
نعم هم يناقشون تزويد كييف
بالاسلحة. ولكن رائحة الطمع
تتسرب في الاعلام الغربي. حيث ان
هناك مفاوضات تدار من تحت
الطاولة الاوروبية الهدف منها
شراء مصانع الاسلحة الاوكرانية.
والمقابل دعمهم العسكري فلا شيء
بالمجان. حتى ان مسؤولين في قطاع
الصناعات الدفاعية البريطانية
زاروا كييف مؤخرا على شروط شراء
بعض شركات الصناعات العسكرية
الاوكرانية بحسب صحيفة التليجراف
ها بينما يتعجب العالم كله من
هذا الكرم الغربي. هنا تتحرك
واشنطن لتدعو مواطنيها لمغادرة
روسيا على الفور. وذلك بسبب
احتمالية وقوع عمليات اعتقال
بدون سند قانوني. فيما دعت فرنسا
وكندا ايضا مواطني الدولتين
لمغادرة على خلفية التوتر في
اوكرانيا. الردود الغربية تتوالى
وهنا بولندا تعزل جميع خريجي
جامعة موسكو للعلاقات الدولية من
مناصبهم. جن جنون الغربيين. وها
هو وزير الدفاع الامريكي يعود
ليؤكد ان الاسابيع المقبلة ستكون
حاسمة في الازمة الاوكرانية.
وبين هذا وذاك جاء الرد الروسي
على لسان متحدث الكرملين ديمتري
بسكوف ان حلفا شمال الاطلسي يؤكد
يوميا عدائه لروسيا ويسعى جاهدا
للانخراط في النزاع الاوكراني
بشكل متزايد. حروب الظلام تتوسع.
الصين وامريكا في حرب باردة تشتد
اكثر فاكثر لتتجه نحو طريق لا
يحمد عقباه. وبعد تبادل واشنطن
وبكين اتهامات ارسال كل منهما
مناطيد خرج الامر عن نطاقه لتعلن
السلطات الامريكية والكندية في
مفاجأة جديدة انها تتلقى الاف
البلاغات حول اجسام طائرة مجهولة
تحلق فوق امريكا الشمالية وفق
وكالة لكن الناطق باسم البيت
الابيض جون كيربي يقول ان الجسم
الطائر الغريب كان يشكل تهديدا
للملاحة الجوية المدنية. مشيرا
الى ان التحقيقات لم تكشف بعد عن
وجود اجهزة تجسس بداخله. ليدخل
امين عام حلف الناتو على الخط
قائلا ان ما حدث في الولايات
المتحدة في الاونة الاخيرة هو
جزء من النشاط الروسي والصيني
المكثف في مراقبة دول حلف الناتو
بحسب رويترز تأتي هذه الاخبار
بعد اسقاط منطاد صيني وثلاثة
اجسام طائرة في سماء امريكا
وكندا خلال الايام القليلة
الماضية. فهل هي مناطيد تجسس امن
حرب من الفضاء الخارجي. وهنا
قائد القيادة المركزية للقوات
الجوية الامريكية الجنرال
جرينكويتش يقول ان اجساما طائرة
دارت في سماء منطقة بالشرق
الاوسط من مسؤولية القيادة
المركزية خلال السنوات القليلة
الماضية لكنه اضاف انها بالونات
مراقبة صينية وفق شبكة فاكس
نيمز. وبعد هذا كله. الرئيس
الامريكي لم وها هو يأمر بتشكيل
فريق استخباراتي للتحري حول هذه
الاجسام الطائرة في البلاد. من
حرب التجسس الى المعارك البحري.
وبعد قيام سفينة تابعة لخفر
السواحل الصيني بتوجيه شعاع ليزر
عسكري الى سفينة دورية تابعة
للبحرية الفلبينية ما ادى لاصابة
طاقمها بعمل مؤقت. الرئاسة
الفلبينية تستدعي السفير الصيني
لتحتج الحادثة بحسب وكالة تاس.
هناك جددت الولايات المتحدة
التزامها بالدفاع عن الفلبين حال
تعرضها لهجوم مسلح في بحر الصين
الجنوبي المتنازع عليه. اصوات
الالم لا تنتهي. الالم يزداد.
والصراخ لم يعد يجدي والحال
التركي السوري يحرك مشاعر العدو
قبل صديق. وهنا يبدو ان الزلزال
المدمر الذي سوريا وتركيا لم
يسقط المنازل والجدران الاسمنتية
والطرقات فقط بل اسقط الحواجز
السياسية وذاب خلافات استعصت
لسنوات على الجهود الدبلوماسية.
لتنحي اليونان الخصومة جانبا مع
تركيا وتهرع للمساعدة في ارض
الكارثة بعيدا عن المماحاكات
السياسية بحسب المراقبين. فهل
ينتهي التوتر بعد ذلك? لنعد الى
الضحايا وبعد ان وجه هذا الشاب
وصيته الاخيرة لوالده واخيه ظنا
منه انه هو من سيفارق الحياة تحت
الانقاض ليتمكن بعد ذلك من
النجاة والخروج من تحت الركام
باعجوبة. لكنه للاسف فقد ثمانية
من عائلته. وهنا رضيع الزلزال
وابن الستين يوما صمد تحت
الانقاض لخمسة ايام وخرج يوزع
ضحكاته بريئة وها هو في المستشفى
ينعم بصحة جيدة لكن مصير والديه
مجهول. الجميع يتمتعون ببراءتك
يا صغيري. فضلا عن الخسائر
البشرية التي وصلت اثنين واربعين
الف قتيل بسبب الزلزال. اتحاد
الشركات والاعمال في تركيا يشير
الى ان الخسائر المادية مقدرة
باكثر من اربعة وثمانين مليار
دولار. مع تحذير من اقتراب في
منطقة بؤرة الزلزال قد ينهي
الحياة تماما في المنطقة ليكمل
ما تركه الزلزال قلوبنا معكم يا
هؤلاء. وهنا الرئيس التركي يؤذن
في اذن مولودة ناجية من الزلزال
ويطلق اسما عليها. فلتسمها امل
يا سيادة الرئيس. الاحداث
والتطورات. في كوريا الشمالية لا
صوت يعلو فوق صوت ابنة الزعيم
كيم جونغ لتصدر ولاول مرة توابع
بريدية تظهر ابنة الزعيم ها هي
جو ايه تمشي مع والدها ممسكة
بيده وتقف لالتقاط صورة تذكارية
مع جنود الجيش الشعبي. لتخرج
التقارير قائلة ان كيم جونج حضر
اسم ابنته جو اي في البلاد واجبر
كل انثى في كوريا تحمل اسم ابنته
ان تسارع لتعديله في شهادة
ميلاد. اذا فلتسارعنا لتعديل
الاسم قبل ان تصبح شهادة الميلاد
شهادة وفاة. يواصل عشرات الالاف
من الاسرائيليين التظاهر ضد
تعديل النظام القضائي. وبهتاف
العار العار هاجمت المعارضة
الائتلاف الحكومي بالكنيست.
الرئيس المصري يقول ان احداث
الفين واحد عشر كلفت الدولة
اربعمائة وخمسين مليار دولار.
مشيرا الى انه لولا وقوف
السعودية والكويت والامارات لما
تجاوزت مصر ازمتها حسب تعبيره.
روسيا تدخل العام الجديد بقوة
والناتو يستعد للمواجهة لكن في
الاراضي الاوكرانية بينما تنشغل
امريكا بحرب التجسس ولا شيء يبعث
على التفاؤل يا اصدقاء.